the author of the brand new book unwoke
how to defeat cultural Marxism in
America
state of Texas
[Applause]
and Cruz Senator I gave the numbers we
see the economy we see two-thirds of the
American people now can't make ends meet
you see people cashing in their
retirement plans to make ends meet
people for Bare Necessities are using
credit cards it's never been this bad
in my lifetime at least Sean the sad
truth is the the sad truth is the
Socialists are in charge of the White
House Joe Biden certainly isn't but the
people he surrounded him with
they have a very simple approach to
everything they want to spend money they
don't have they want to raise taxes on
you they've Unleashed record inflation
this budget that Biden put out would
create a 50 trillion dollar national
debt and their view is they can just
keep printing money and unleashing
inflation and borrowing money from China
and it is wildly irresponsible you know
what's not in this budget
funds to secure our Southern border that
they want to fund 87 000 new IRS agents
but they don't have funds for for
significant numbers of new border patrol
agents they don't have funds for
significant number of new DEA agents to
stop the fentanyl crisis the over a
hundred thousand overdoses that happened
last year on Biden's watch this is a tax
and spend budget and amazingly some of
the taxes they've got 5.5 trillion
dollars in new taxes in this budget that
includes taxes directly on energy so
remember all the Democrats who said gosh
we want your gas prices low they were
lying Joe Biden's budget is saying he
wants gas prices much much higher and
he's going to put taxes on him or he
wants to in order to drive the prices up
now here's the good thing
the chances of this budget being enacted
in the law are 0.0 percent this is a
political document we have a republican
house they ain't going to do it
Senator and the amazing thing is Biden
knows that he knows that this will never
pass so this is him telling you what he
wants to do and what he wants to do is
is really extreme and really dangerous
and this is at a point where two-thirds
of the American people are living
paycheck to paycheck and and literally
every American household the first two
years of Biden's presidency has paid
over ten thousand dollars in Biden
inflation taxes now people can't afford
this type of of economy that he wants to
build it's never going to work I'm glad
you're right I don't think it's going to
pass I don't think the house will ever
pass it but what does it say about them
wanting to pass it
well you know there used to be such a
thing as moderate Democrats in in
Congress they've been driven out the
people setting the agenda this is Bernie
Sanders's budget this is AOC this is
Elizabeth Warren and and let me show you
just some amazing stats
um just on a quick review
uh of of the budget all right here's how
many times the following words appear in
the budget equity
63 times
climate 148 times
environmental justice 25 times
transgender eight times intersex which I
have no idea what that is seven times
none of us know either
[Laughter]
side of that John I I hope we don't have
to yell people think go ahead real quick
we got a break
so things the American people care about
inflation only 10 times fentanyl twice
border security eight times police four
times law enforcement nine times crime
24 times in gas prices three times they
tell you who they are Senator Ted Cruz
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else